alright as promised here he is man of
the hour the Minnesota Vikings along
with Adam Thielen they're taking on the
Chicago Bears this week he's been banged
up recently I'm assuming he's playing
this week here courtesy of Old Spice
foamer and he's also honestly my
favorite Family Feud player maybe maybe
of all time
he's not a min Stefon Diggs how are you
Stefan I'm always great to hear from you
Stefon Diggs always great to hear from
you first up you playing this weekend we
can see on every Sunday night I'm back
in action I'm back you're back in action
what was it like to be out of action for
you
it was terrible heartbreaking I hate
missing games and the bye week
it helped me but it didn't happen
because me miss another week of football
but I'm so excited to get back to Target
and get back to being oh my gosh okay I
know what's what's up with feeling this
year Stefan I mean he's obviously as
good as ever but it seems like he's just
he's just cleaning it all up right now
your team isn't there's nothing new to
me it's not a surprise to me because I
see the guy on a daily basis but the
time he puts in the things that he do to
get ready for a game and as far as I
guess it's just mindset you know as a
player you love playing with guys like
that you know that's a good friend of
mine one of my close friends as far as
like I consider him my brother or family
so far like his preparation is no is no
slouch in as far as like him having
success in game I'm not surprised I let
it right I would be surprised that's my
guy
yeah I'm wondering if you share a
kinship with him because your fifth
round pick he's a guy that nobody
expected
from a small school up there in
Minnesota to do what you guys are doing
together for the hometown Vikings yeah
it's a crazy story especially from from
his standpoint I would say more him
because you know he's probably Minnesota
you know it's like that it's like a it's
like that fairy tale is like that it's
like that dream come true that all the
kids one thing he he's definitely in a
position to make it all all come full
circle for kids coming out of Minnesota
that want to be great I want to do all
those things he's just a living
a living testament to say you can do it
and so what do you guys do together you
say you're you're tight your friends I
mean what do you guys do well we don't
hang out as much as people would think
just because we have to totally
different uh two totally different
things to do for fun he loves to go I'm
just getting in the Gulf I don't go up
like that what else does he do he
actually he loves golf as much as he has
he has a thing in his house I think so I
don't go out too much you know I'm more
of a I'm a homebody myself so I don't
leave the house as much okay but we
still have a great relationship in this
I mind I'm actually I just need to try
that yeah I mean I know it's you hate
the cold but if you get a look you you
guys can get one of those sort of I mean
upscale I know I'm gonna blow it what is
the we call it a house a nice house with
a hot you think I mean you can you can
you can get warm in there Stefan don't
don't blow it right you know I mean but
you're from you're from Maryland aren't
you yeah it gets pretty cold out there
too but okay tell you a secret
Minnesota coat is just a little
different oh I was there for the Super
Bowl last year man I know what you're
talking about
oh yeah it was like so do you have a
heated garage
you got you got that going on then I do
that I do I do have you to get right
just cuz when I like a better morning I
don't I don't want to have to start my
car and wait a little while I got it I
want to shoot this shoot straight to
work okay you know me you already know I
do you know we kind of go way back like
when you were just busting out coming
out of Maryland I'm like this guy Stefon
Diggs has got something going on and
let's get him on the show I was like two
years ago now yeah you may be so no
you're the one who's making me feel
Stefon Diggs here on the Rich Eisen show
so what what do I make are your your
team everybody came in thought okay here
comes Kurt cousins just add him to a
team that that that was up 7-nothing one
possession into the NFC Championship
game and they make the Super Bowl and
you guys are entering in second place
going into Chicago what what what should
i and everybody make of the Vikings
through through non games too fun for us
I would say it's a great great spot to
be in you know we are definitely our
hands we took it one day at a time one
game at a time and it always gonna come
down to preparation you know as far as
like I would contributor early adversity
that we had earlier in the year with the
ups and downs and the good things
happening bad things that we showing
signs of being we can't be good
we just got to do things the right way
it's kind of like all coming full circle
right now so our preparation is gonna be
key these upcoming weeks and this week
is gonna be definitely to start a point
then your team is fully healthy on the
offensive side of the ball coming in
right yes yes from all I know you know
I'm doing an injury before but I knew I
was on it so I'm feeling good I'm I'm
back to normal and I look forward to
because you know we got we gotta cook
back I'm a 33 plays a huge part and also
he does it he's a special player you
know yeah that ability that he can take
in any gimmick any any given playing at
least we saw last week I was watching it
all right he make one of them because he
didn't score you know that's something
we want to net never let fly because we
have a thing of getting caught from
behind so I'm gonna make fun of him for
a while okay you can do that Stefan I
mean you can affect when you see the way
that you won the divisional playoff last
year when you watch it back what do you
think of Stefan's eggs um it was
definitely a good memory as I was saying
but with all that happens throughout the
year with all the adversity that we we
had to battle through and you know that
game in itself was part one of the best
games I was ever a part of just because
not necessarily just a play that it
happened but the game you know the game
was exciting we came out shooting we
came out firing we were scoring fast
defense was playing lights-out second
half rolling around you breathe gets
back in the game you know you read those
Drew Brees does it's just a it was
exciting time to be you know being
around and being involved in such a
great great game but for me it didn't go
as planned you know it ended really
really bad so I was like uh that that
next game we didn't play to the best
possibility no matter what how it came
up how it would it came down so we just
didn't it it wasn't good enough but we
hadn't we have a new year we have a new
season every opportunity is a new opera
every new opportunity is big for us
especially comes this upcoming week I'm
so excited
where's the ball do you still have that
ball that game ball I'm not I'm not
we won't yet come on where's that
football the one that you threatened you
known don't read things like that
because I think you're trying to hunt me
down and find it there it's in my house
right now
in the face combining a Tommy check it
out yeah well certainly if you've got a
heated girl she'll come back you know
for sure hey your teammate ever seen
Griffin how's he doing it looks like
he's back you know it's very rare that a
teammate if you will goes down due to
mental health issues and I'm just
wondering how his struggle and return
right now sits in your locker room and
you guys being teammates with him it's a
great spot because you know we looked at
we look at everyone as family especially
in our in our building as far as later
our players are not in the team
synagogues on our team we love we love
you in saying we love you up and we make
sure we're there for you no matter what
so I was like having them back you know
I was just everybody was happy to see
him and everybody's happy to see him
haven't I been getting better actually
made it I know he missed football we
definitely miss having him not just on a
football field just his personality and
the energy that he brings day in and day
out
we're just so happy to have him back now
hopefully we can still be toes
beat it beat a guy that he can lean on
when Tom I need jobs because I know
those guys I mean where everyone's gonna
be talking about Khalil Mack going in
the game I'll tell you that on Sunday
night you know you definitely definitely
make plays and uh um I watch them for a
while so as far as like a defensive play
wise we gonna be good I'm you know major
then okay tell me about your Old Spice
foamer words I don't think I've ever
said to you before Stephane well you
know apparently it can be upgraded from
what I'm told on I see here we have a
post-fight introducing a new form of
body wash it sticks to your body it's
not like other body wash - it just falls
off and goes down and draining
definitely is if you want to upgrade you
push our routine you can find them in
these upon a minute local uh what if you
find it in target so and you looking
forward and you you wanna you want to
smell good you want to look good
there you go okay now before we we
depart ways here Stefon Diggs with you
going to Chicago and me to the rest of
my show and then we will hopefully meet
again soon
you know I went up to you when I saw you
on the field in Los Angeles before your
game against the Rams I interrupted your
pregame routine to tell you what I'm
gonna tell the rest of the audience
right now your your appearance on family
feud that's the fond eggs was with
something else fast money question leave
it blank you said what was the word you
said for the like the gray jacket it was
a cannot leave like you either back
there sure he said well you said you
said in leave it in so what is the
backstory to that because Steve Harvey
made up made a whole filet mignon meal
out of that one
and I want to get back home you just did
and I said it would be myself but like I
just want to make sure even I'm good at
it but I said now only said in because I
could have been like a pie in the oven
it could have been like you're making it
worse define you make it worse it could
have been something food-related is what
you're saying
it mop is my point exactly you know pile
of it is the perfect you could leave it
in for couple more minutes what was the
reaction when when you got back to your
huddle right now you're gonna see Sunday
night they were all out there what was
the reaction yeah I just really feel
like everybody was thinking something
else for it see that everybody was
thinking something else or we all were
on the same page and I'm gonna leave
that up for no you were in a different
book you were in what was your reaction
when you got back to your locker room
when they when they saw you for the
first time in Minnesota you know it's
crazy because it we shot it like
probably six seven months ago
morning lows one point one offseason
while we were in LA so right
so pretty late in my coaches I've been I
was telling people for a while just make
sure you watch it comes on it's pretty
funny and when they finally taught my
coaches my coaches died lastly it's
definitely something for something to
also remember you know
don't forget about even Zimmer Zimmer
liked it Zimmer found it for that one
needs leave it alone exactly what you
should have said hey Stephan always
enjoy our chats loved watching you play
I mean Lana I love your commercial where
everything sticks to your hand you've
really you've really done wonders with
your first couple of years in the league
and I look forward to seeing more from
you thank you guys I appreciated it you
know family fused together okay let's so
okay so there's lots to do here ice
fishing with Filan hanging out in the
the heated garage and family feud that's
how we're gonna roll and I'll see you
Sunday Night Football now Stefon Diggs
that's Stefan with an F oh and digs on
Twitter right here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience